so this video is going to go over some
of the beginner and advanced tips to law
breakers character Titan so we're going
to do this in a few parts you're going
to put this up first we're going to go
over the kits and its basics of its
weapons and abilities and how to be
mobile with Titan then the first part is
going to be offense second part is going
to be defense and then the final part is
going to be how to counter this
character this abuse for for players who
have a problem fighting Titan or our
players who are Titan and then kind of
learn to what to watch out for so let's
get started
so first off Titans main weapon of
choice is a rocket launcher called
hammerhead hammerhead is useful for
doing tons of AoE damage to groups of
enemies that are grouped up with this
weapon can also be used for rocket jump
as well to gain some boost but we'll
talk about that later
hammerhead does 225 damage on impact in
between 75 and 135 splash damage which
will kill most enemies in 3 to 4 rockets
the hammerhead can also blow up the
Rockets in midair by pressing right
click on your mouse or left trigger on
council next up is Titan secondary
called CRISPR which shoots an electrical
current towards the enemy that deals 25
damage over time causing low health
enemies to die very quickly 25 damage
doesn't really seem a lot but the enemy
is being hit multiple times a second
which leads to tons of damage very
quickly
as for titans abilities his first one is
a ground pound called pulverize this
attack will do good a OE when attacked
by a group but it's only really useful
if the enemy has a low enough health as
this doesn't really do too much damage
or you can use this as a getaway from a
situation you won't necessarily survive
the next ability is a mind called the
neutron mine which slows the speed of
enemies when trapped by making it an
easy kill for them so for coming around
the corner though the neutron mine down
they'll get trapped in it little bit
slowed makes it an easy kill and then
his last ability is Berserker which is
Titans ultimate when activated Titan
gains health and increased damage output
by shooting electricity out of his hands
it shoots just as fast as the crisper
but instead of doing 25 damage it does
33 damage overtime and then lastly for
his kit
to be mobile Titan is one of the few
characters if not the only character in
the game without an ability primarily
used for mobility so as shown in the
clip you want to rocket jump right out
of spawn so you can get a boost of speed
really quickly and catch up with your
team and you can also rocket jump twice
without taking damage if done quick
enough because of the small time the
time of invincibility immediately after
leaving spawn once you're in the middle
of a zero-g field which is most of the
middle of the map use the left control
on PC or down the d-pad on console to
boost yourself forward by shooting
backwards every character can do this
but Titans is the most effective because
the bigger the weapon the bigger the
boost use when firing backwards so Titan
is going to have a lot more boost when
shooting backwards but characters such
as racing gunslinger aren't going to be
going so fast now I'm not a pro at
rocket jumping and I'm also not a pro be
hopping as well so I do apologize for
the shitty example but you kind of get
the point now that we're done with those
abilities let's start with how to use
Titan so first up is often Titan is and
is mostly a defense character but does
also put up a great fight on offense as
well even with the lack of a mobility
type ability so since the Hammerhead is
a slow fire rate and a reload speed it's
key to always hit your shots so if we
are in common with your accuracy follow
a teammate that normally charges the
objective by supporting them and
suppressing enemies with the Hammerhead
or use the neutron mine to trap them so
your team can light them up real quickly
if you're confident with your aim then
it's possible to charge the objective
yourself and survive with Titan Titans
high health pool and high damage this is
mostly useful for game mode so just
uplink where you can take the satellite
and then bring it back to your spawn
blitzball is a little bit of a problem
but because since he doesn't have a
mobility type ability he has to walk in
and hopefully doesn't get killed in
there such a except people such as
wraith who can slide into the objective
or gunslinger who can teleport in there
very quickly without being seen so
that's why next up is defense and this
is route iton excels on game modes like
uplink and overcharge defending your
base is super easy by placing a neutron
mine on the objective and continuing to
throw one on once it disappears sub when
your enemy chose to take the objective
back they'll be trapped and killed
almost instantly by
hammerhead or crisper you can also
activate your ultimate if a Qatari and
team starts to have groups of people
pushing at the same time just in case
you need to clear the objective very
quickly and then lastly this is going to
be how to counter Titan the primary
counter of the Titan is fast characters
such as Wraith and assassin also being
in the air and far away is super hard
for him because of the range and slow
fire rate of the rocket launcher so be
aware when fighting characters in the
air and make sure to lead your shots and
remember you can blow up the rockets
yourself if you're off target this is a
guide on how to use Titan I hope you
guys did enjoy this took a lot of time
to analyze this to both betas this is
this should be releasing the day of or
if not a day after the game so hopefully
everything's up to date if anyway I hope
you guys did enjoy that hopefully this
did make you a better Titan player or if
you're just here to figure out how to
defeat tight and hopefully this makes
you aware of how to fight a Titan let me
know in the comments below if this did
help you or not if it did please be sure
to leave a like it really does help me
out as much as you think it doesn't and
while you're at while you're at it
subscribe for more lawbreakers content
and then right next to that there should
be a bell icon hit that so you can be
part of my notification squad and then
never miss one of my uploads the most
recent video is going to be on the
screen that's wherever I talk about my
review for lawbreakers and how I
personally feel about the game and if
it'll succeed or not also if you have
any suggestions on other characters you
want me to do for guides leave them in
the comments I'm glad they do a video on
them but with that guys thanks for
watching and I'll see you guys later
peace out